strain my day jockey block my night all
day nice anyone de saw some about John
Jones I think because I got a theory I
got an older brother theory and I feel
like dudes who have badass older
brothers can [ __ ] take it like
Weidman Weidman had an older brother and
him and the older brother apparently
according to some of his interviews they
you know his older brother beat him up a
gym and make stuff like Matt Hughes two
twins imagine looking at yourself every
day just trying to beat up your shell
happen and it's just a dead even coating
park just a war jim miller dan miller a
lot of those guys my brother used to
beat me up but i never not beat me up
but just like sock my shoulder like if i
would fart he would shock me for i have
to sit there and I would take and I
would never fight back no no but like in
boxers the the Smith family Liam Smith
uncle Smith there's four brothers at
three are world champions
Golda Miller Mike a Miller all to split
yeah savages monsters man does it comes
on whether yup the Lausanne brothers
they know Carol brother
Nogueira brothers [ __ ] twins their right
- there's a bunch man I do so many mug
Shogun and ninja oh here's something
that [ __ ] rock your world or not rock
your world
but if Jon Jones wasn't such you know a
[ __ ] up for lack of better terms he
would we're not even having this
conversation that Mighty Mouse is the
best ever he'd be just going based off
his regular schedule now he'd be 13 14
time world champ it's no one beat him
and he'd probably find that heavyweight
and having that built - going down his
best-ever well he still got a chance
I mean John John's only 30 years old
which is crazy because that means he's
really about to jump into his prime I'd
say it like an athlete's prime for
combat sports I feel like it's somewhere
around 30 to 32 for heavyweight I see I
don't think everyone I think the lighter
weight classes it's earlier but looked
at the welterweights
the champs are always a lot around that
age except for GSP I think you won the
title when he was in his late 20s yeah
right honey when is a tyron woodley is
what 33 yeah yeah that's fair I mean
yeah that's exactly what the related oh
and John Jones so it's right how old's
Robbie Jon Jones is
his suspension comes up in July do you
hear what Dana White said today i text
you yeah they're going to fight there
was a Fred Nakamoto right yeah bred a
komodo interviewed Dana White in from
ESPN he said that uh BC will fight John
Jones on if but if John Jones isn't
ready by I think July card yeah July
29th yeah if he's not ready by them then
he's gonna fight Jimmy man wha and then
they'll fight down the road crazy so no
warm-up for John Jones if he does want
one then what do you think about that do
you think that's smart for John or do
you think John should take a warm-up he
should take a warm-up the UFC should
give him a warm up because Joe when has
it ever worked when a guy takes this
much time off and just throw him right
to the top of the heat sink I know were
think of Chael Sonnen like there's a lot
of guys and people go wolf Dominick Cruz
Tom Cruise don't fight Cody garment TJ
Dillashaw after all that time right I
thought of mrs. sake who's a tough guy
but too cocky and then he went right
into TJ I say no a warm but TJ was no
the teacher was a big gap no I know but
at least he didn't fight people at first
fight back ain't being TJ right but you
know that he got injured after the mid
segaki fighting it was another year plus
true boy fought again and she and he
might be the outlier here but I'm just
an outline he's not like but but he's
not as good in the first fight if you
look at him at the TJ fight and then you
look at him in the second fight when we
fought you're right favorite he's way
better in your eye fake right he's more
lean he's fitter and he dealt with a lot
of the problems that he has his serious
plantar fasciitis or BAM yeah have you
ever had that no I heard a [ __ ]
nightmare I had to deal with it and you
look at it what about it's it's a deep
like a this fashio in the bottom of your
feet tears
you can't even like you can't get out of
bed to warm up it's a [ __ ] nightmare
and also your dominant Cruz is all
footwork and what happened to have three
tours a CL he took a long time off and
his feet just weren't strong enough to
keep up with his training because his
training is so foot before yeah movement
yeah my momma got it yeah back to the
point should John get a warm up your you
know the grand scheme of things I
understand we want these big paydays you
want them the big ratings so you toss
them DC John John's a huge raider right
but if something happens like Ronda
Rousey lost
why does we gave Ronda warm-ups who get
paid on that
draw and then she fights huge draw but
when you just cost them right - they top
it's a one and done man well it make
sense to me they were worried I guess
you know with the sale you know you buy
something for like four billion dollars
you want to you want to maximize your
profits you know it's just the issue
comes up with purist
[Applause]
[Music]